last year Allen won new artist of the
year at the CMA Awards and new male
artist of the year at the ACM Awards
tomorrow night he'll co-host the CBS and
Paramount plus special New Year's Eve
live Nashville's big bash the five-hour
celebration will Air live from Music
City featuring nearly 50 performances
from country music's biggest stars Jimmy
Allen what's up baby
it's good to see you we're so glad
you're here so tell us man what's going
on with you co-hosting Nashville's
biggest bash what does it mean to you it
means a lot because I was a performer on
it last year then I got to call uh uh to
be a co-host this year what was the
pitch what'd they say to you you pick up
the phone they say Jimmy I don't know my
manager Coleman say hey he's got an
offer for you to cause Nationals big
bash I was like oh yeah I mean say less
yeah so you know shout out to my homies
uh you know Robert Deaton and the CBS
family for letting me do it you know I
went from performer it's a co-host
hopefully next year you know you know
Nashville's big bash featuring Jimmy
Allen
but you're not just cold
Mormon too right yeah performing should
be fine okay so anything you can tell us
about that performance it's going to be
fun okay you know I'm a guaranteed good
time I'm gonna sing a song with some
words
I'm reading about your your uh ritual
that you always do before you go on
stage there's a song You're always
saying I I was surprised to hear this I
thought you were making it up but you
actually know the words what is it oh
it's uh popular from the song from the
uh uh Play Wicked like I love musical
theater like one of my dreams is to go
to Broadway I want to play Aaron Burr on
Hamilton so two guys I know both played
Aaron Burr one here in Chicago one in
New York I mean uh one uh here in New
York and Chicago so Wayne Brady did it
in Chicago yeah and Leslie Odom did it
here that's right I want to do it for
people no no what I want to do it what's
your favorite line from popular I want
to hear you sing it what is it uh uh
uh I'll teach you the proper boys when
you talk to boys little ways to flirting
flowers
I love that why is that a good song for
you I I didn't I don't know it's
something about musical theater that
just puts me in a good place you know
what I mean a lot of people yeah I did
it in high school college I actually had
a scholarship offer to go to amda
American Musical and dramatic Academy
here in New York but um so you want to
act two yeah more than just singing yeah
acting to me hosting a show uh acting
that's just as important to me as music
like music isn't if someone said okay
Jimmy you can you'll win Grammys you'll
win CMA Awards you have multiple number
ones you'll sell out stadiums but you'll
never perform on TV or do anything with
television acting I'd say no wow in a
heartbeat because it's just as important
I would rather Play House of Blues size
places I love House of Blues by the way
the rest of my life
and be and never win a Grammy never win
a CMA to still be able to do television
um what does it mean to now be a
successful black artist in country music
it means a lot
um it for me it goes to show that
nothing replaces hard work you know what
I mean and you know
no matter what you feel or what you
think about uh your skin color holding
you back or your gender holding you back
or whatever
again no matter how people feel about
you that does not replace or do not does
not determine your work ethic and the
quality of music you put out right so to
me you know it's it's been it's been
great to show that okay boom I've been
able to come in as a you know as a black
guy from Tennessee I mean that lives
Tennessee from Delaware yeah you know
work hard meet people but also surround
myself with great songwriters of course
great producer of course and be honest
with myself about the music because I
feel like sometimes we'll as artists we
can put out a song We love that might
not be the best song is that the best
career move and just making sure it's
there and I tell people before you put
out any single the radio whatever would
you bet your career on this song If you
can't ask yourself like Barry Gordy used
to do a Motown would you spend your last
dollar on a sandwich or this song he
does say that yeah I mean so for me it's
like every I can honestly say every
single that I put out I would bet my
career on it and I feel like that's
important to keep the integrity and the
quality of of Music That's powerful and
you've also you're a dad you've got
three children and you had a bit of an
RSV scare can you talk tell us a little
bit about is your daughter okay yeah
Zara's fine
um RSV was something I never heard of
never heard of neither and I'm one of
the people that when you hear about it's
like testimony section at church you
know you stand up and you kind of tell
your testimony what you went through
because it inspires other people and so
that's why for me uh I mean my wife it
was important to partner with uh Santa
Fe to spread the knowledge of RSV
because so many people don't ever yeah
never heard of it and there's tons of
information you can visit a site but
she's okay that's good she's great now
walking around smiling so so as we head
into 2023 Jimmy tell us what you're most
looking for in less than 30 seconds the
end of 2023 no as we head into 2023 what
are you most looking forward to New Year
forward to continue to have a healthy
family there you go yeah that is big but
now music uh uh possibilities of you
know working on TV shows state of
special movies and Hamilton
live in Nashville's big bash tomorrow
night that's New Year's Eve right here
on CBS and on Paramount Plus